[Musique]
ils sont une vingtaine de collégiens à
recevoir un prix pour leur oeuvre la
femme mosaïque cette classe de 4e du
collège célimène gaudieux à la
saline-les-hauts a remporté le premier
prix célimène julien elles ont fait des
portraits premier voulait et on a
verbalisé sur cette pauvreté
ajouter des touches deux heures chacun
utiliser la technique
choix
petit on est amer
vers 7 heures finale il y avait du
collage sur le thème de la femme
réunionnaise ces collégiens ont
représenté la femme dans toutes ses
expressions six heures de travail en
collaboration avec l'artiste laurie
beaudet ont été nécessaires à la
réalisation de ce tableau aux multiples
facettes à me représenter la femme sur
d'autres formes et ses valeurs
de dire que ce sont des femmes sont très
importants et le
la réussite scolaire passe par
l'appropriation de certains réflexes de
certaines envies de 7,1 volonté et à
travers justement les arts plastiques la
poésie comme ce matin nous offrons nous
excitons la curiosité des élèves et à
travers sa curiosité nouvelle souvent
des obtiennent de meilleurs résultats
scolaires
donc c'est tout le but de notre volonté
au département renfoncer la réussite
scolaire de nos collègues
le prix célimène existe depuis 2005
créé par le conseil départemental il
valorise dans le cadre d'un concours
artistiques amateurs la créativité des
femmes mais aussi les jeunes
[Musique]
m